an actor gets Blown Away by his
African-American DNA
he has to put a smile on his face to
learn he's mixed race on an episode of
the PBS show Finding Your Roots that's
when Jesse looks at his hair
actor Joe manganello
which is Italian for mangello
learned his great grandfather was a
black man descended from slaves and he
says he totally understands himself more
now he understands himself more telling
Rolling Stone quote there are things
that make sense now it feels like I
spent my whole life looking at myself in
a mirror completely out of focus and all
of a sudden I could see myself clearly
for the first time
well that's hilarious and I'm told he's
already put in his request for
reparations
[Applause]
and a Kardashian
yeah
but for him it's just in time for Black
History Month
although now that he's black being from
Boston means he has to kick his own ass
[Laughter]
that was a smear unfair smear to all the
lovely people in Boston
but he welcomed the news and said it
fills a gap in his identity he's always
felt was missing and while being seven
percent black instead of 100 Italian
doesn't change much of anything now at
least he could tell chicks hey once you
go seven percent black
[Music]
Tyrus is that enough of a percentage to
allow him to feel different like can he
claim that his whole like is his life
now in perspective with seven percent
first of all uh welcome welcome to the
club
laughs
[Applause]
the problem with his seven percent
Blackness is he let his 93 whiteness do
the talking yeah
we don't say stuff like that yeah
exactly it all makes sense now what
makes sense bruh what exactly makes
sense like you the only thing that makes
sense is your white privilege is gone
now negro so uh
[Applause]
take care of your kids get a job
and listen to more rap
[Laughter]
welcome to the group yes exactly
so uh
Johnny
do you know that we did this thing on
the five uh 23andMe and Jesse Waters has
one more kids yeah
that's why I don't do it that's right
I was a single Marine for eight years
you keep keep the swab out of my mouth
that's true what do you think of this
listen if I were a six and a half foot
tall ruggedly handsome single straight
or straight white male
um I'd probably want this too I mean if
Jason Momoa was taking all my all my uh
uh characters away from movies all my
rolls away I would need something to
spice it up and and get my career back
the real question is what's seven
percent is it you know I'm 50 carbon
fiber
which where does the seven percent lie
you know that's true
PAB is he now more attractive to you
[Laughter]
Henry Louis Gates just said that you
know there is no such thing as racial
Purity and it really does seem to be the
case every there's always a surprise
everybody who has this done everyone
I've known who has it done and you have
a lot of brown in your background
s
I've never actually got it done
so stupid
it's so stupid I didn't know where to go
with that
we had a good run so I finished your
point I apologize
that I thought it was interesting also
that he found out that there's no
manganello anywhere in his blood so
somebody lied and uh this is why I don't
want to get this done because I don't
want to hear these secrets about my
family
do you really believe that he knows who
he is now cat
it's just more like how I don't know who
he is yeah
he was never now in an Adam Sandler
movies no but it is like how identity
politics becomes kind of an ego trip but
also they gave his DNA to PBS so he gave
his DNA to the government yeah that's
true usually you like give it away then
the government like takes it which is
like they should scary yeah but he I
mean I grew up in a house where like I
was into Barney and stuff and my dad was
like okay but just know this is
government propaganda
so I don't think everyone was raised
like that but as someone who was raised
that way I'm like what a fool yeah I
want my DNA back but that's a lot of
work I've wanted my DNA back a few times
oh man I think we gotta
I think we've got to go now
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else